- [Dion] At the beginning of last year,
Morgan Stanley equity strategist
Michael Wilson was one
of the few to predict stock market losses.
He was proven right as the S&P 500
had its worst year since 2008.
- [Mike] But it makes sense
why we're seeing this type
of price action.
We do have this collision
between tightening Fed
and slowing growth.
This year, he's projecting
that stocks will fall even further.
I'm going to explain just
how far Wilson thinks stocks
will tumble, why he believes the market
won't recover this year
and break down what the numbers tell us
about the current state of US equities.
Let's get into it.
- [Mike] Given that we're about to enter
the last calendar month
of the first quarter later this week,
we think the risk of stocks
falling further is high.
- In a note written in late February,
Michael Wilson said he expects
the S&P 500 to fall 25%
from its current levels this year.
That would knock the
benchmark US stock index down
to levels it hasn't touched
since the spring of 2020.
This is well below the norm
among equity analysts at the big banks
and it's got many calling
him the biggest bear
on Wall Street.
So why is Wilson so bearish?
First, he argues that stocks
are currently very expensive,
given the risks that the market is facing.
He points to what's known
as the equity risk premium
or the expected return
for stocks versus an investment
in US Treasury bonds.
According to Morgan
Stanley's calculations,
that's at the lowest level since 2007.
Second, Wilson says that even
though stock earnings
are expected to decline,
analysts are being far too
generous with their projections.
He thinks the companies
are going to underperform
and that will push stock
prices down even further.
And third, Wall Street's
biggest bear agrees
with many other strategists
who say the Federal Reserve
is far from done raising US interest rates
and tightening financial conditions.
If rates go higher than
investors are expecting,
that will put even more pressure
on companies and consumers.
The data certainly suggests
there are reasons to be worried
about stock prices.
Earnings for companies in the
S&P 500 are expected to fall
by nearly 5% in the latest quarter.
That will be the worst
since third quarter of 2020.
And companies' net profit margins
or the percentage of every dollar
of sales they make as
profit is expected to fall
for the sixth straight quarter.
The Fed's latest survey of loan officers
also shows banks keep
raising their standards
and fewer companies are
coming to them for loans.
There's also the fact that
investors can earn close
to 5% by keeping their money
in one-year US Treasury bonds,
which are considered risk-free
since the US government
has never defaulted.
To be sure, many top money managers,
like the equity strategists
at JPMorgan believe
stock prices will rebound
from 2022's big losses
because the Fed will reverse course
and start lowering interest
rates later this year.
They believe that will drive money back
into the market and push
stock prices higher.
But Wilson and other strategists
at places like Barclays,
Deutsche Bank and Jeffries
see the Fed holding rates high
in order to battle inflation even
in the face of a painful recession.
Only time will tell who has it right.